[Musik]
neuer monat neuer podcast freitag der
erste april ist der faz früh denker
guten morgen und herzlich willkommen zu
dieser premiere den faz früh denker den
kennen sich vielleicht schon als
newsletter das wichtigste des morgens
gibt es jetzt aber nicht mehr nur zum
lesen sondern auch zum hören immer
montags bis freitags um 6 uhr morgens ja
das sind die themen heute russland
akzeptiert gaszahlungen nur noch in
rubel in vielen bundesländern fallen die
meisten corona regeln weg und die
gruppen für die fußball wm in katar
werden heute ausgelost dazu gleich mehr
hier noch die nacht in kürze also
meldungen die es eben gerade noch
reingekommen sind
der ukrainische präsident wirft zwei
wichtigen mitgliedern des
sicherheitsapparats fahrrad vor und
kündigt in der nacht per videobotschaft
konsequenzen an in versform melden
ukrainische truppen die rückeroberung
mehrerer siedlungen die
lebensmittelpreise dürften weiter
deutlich ansteigen sicherlich im
zweistelligen prozentbereich da sagt der
präsident des handelsverbands
deutschland in einem zeitungsinterview
in shanghai beginnt ein neuer corona
lockdown für millionen und die frauen
des vfl wolfsburg ziehen souverän ins
halbfinale der champions league ein
durch ein 2 0 gegen den fc arsenal
die texte heute hat sebastian reuter
geschrieben redakteur vom dienst bei
faz.net mein name ist jan malte andresen
und ich freue mich dass sie diesen tag
mit uns beginnen
[Musik]
von heute an müssen europäische kunden
russisches gas über rubel konnten bei
russischen banken bezahlen damit wolle
russland seine finanzielle und
wirtschaftliche souveränität stärken
sagt russlands präsident putin
auch deswegen hat sich bundeskanzler
olaf scholz bestehende verträge noch mal
ganz genau angeschaut darin steht drin
dass in euro gezahlt wird manchmal
dollar wenn der regel in euro und ich
habe in dem gespräch mit dem russischen
präsidenten klar gemacht dass das auch
so bleiben wird und wie seine
vorstellungen sind dass das geschehen
kann das ist das was wir jetzt genau
anschauen werden aber auf alle fälle
gilt für die unternehmen dass sie in
euro zahlen wollen können und werden
rollen können und werden aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium heißt es man
werde das dekret aus russland prüfen und
bewerten sobald es vorliegt
die bundesregierung versucht ja seit
einigen tagen den vorwurf zu entkräften
deutschland und andere westliche staaten
finanzierten mit ihren zahlungen für
russische energie putins krieg in der
ukraine
da war auch zu hören russland könne
wegen der sanktionen mit dem geld
gegenwärtig nichts anfangen dem
widersprechen aber fachleute und
ökonomen und auch italiens
ministerpräsident mario draghi erklärte
deutschland und italien finanzieren
zusammen mit allen ländern die gas öl
kohle und getreide importieren den
russischen krieg daran gibt es keinen
zweifel
in diesem krieg ziehen sich die
russischen einheiten in der ukraine
nicht zurück sondern positionieren sich
neu zu dieser einschätzung kommt die
nato zugleich ist die hauptstadt kiew
nach ansicht der us-regierung weiter
stark durch luftangriffe gefährdet
ukrainische streitkräfte meldeten
gestern intensive kämpfe und
artilleriebeschuss in der ost ukraine
russland bereitet die mögliche annexion
weiterer gebiete vor die sogenannten
volksrepublik 'nen in der ost ukraine
haben zitat referenten über den beitritt
zur russischen föderation angekündigt
auch das von georgien abtrünnigen gebiet
südossetien will entsprechende
juristische schritte ergreifen alle drei
gebiete werden seit langem von russland
kontrolliert dass sie als staaten
anerkannt hat sie hängen wirtschaftliche
und politisch von moskau ab das an ihre
bewohner schon russische pässe verteilen
ließ
bundeskanzler scholz berät heute mit den
kommunen über die aufnahme von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine
der deutsche städtetag hatte im vorfeld
verbindliche absprachen für die schnelle
verteilung und registrierung der
flüchtlinge und eine übernahme der
kosten gefordert derzeit herrsche zwar
eine weiterhin große hilfsbereitschaft
aber auch großes chaos einen mal ganz
anderen blick auf die gegenwärtige
situation wird der aktuelle faz podcast
für deutschland da geht es um die frage
was menschen mit russischen wurzeln
eigentlich zum ukraine konflikt sagen
und wie er für streit in vielen
russlanddeutschen familien sorgt auch in
der von anastasia die seit mehr als 15
jahren in deutschland lebt und ein
ballettstudio in frankfurt leitet meine
familie zb wenn ich rede und ich
verstehe die haben anderes bild dann
habe ich gedacht okay ich sehe das nicht
so machen
einfach dass wir nicht streiten erstens
und zweitens ist es besser für mich
meine familie dort weil sie leben dort
ja gefährlich für die gefälligst ja für
mich ist ja sowieso gefängnisses
meisterschaft überhaupt nächster zeit
nach ursachen pflegen der affiche der
nicht verhaftet werden oder so wie
putins propaganda russlanddeutschen
familien zerreißt das hören sie im faz
podcast für deutschland
es ist freitag es geht ins wochenende
und danach wird vieles nicht mehr so
sein wie heute stichwort corona
maßnahmen in berlin entfallen ab heute
schon viele der bisherigen core ohne
regeln die meisten anderen bundesländer
ziehen am wochenende danach nur in
hamburg und mecklenburg vorpommern wird
die sogenannte hot spot regel angewendet
überall sonst nur noch vorkehrungen zum
basisschutz also etwa eine masken
pflichten häusern und pflegeheimen oder
in bussen bahnen und flugzeugen weiter
möglich ist auch eine testpflicht an
schulen einkaufen hingegen geht ohne
maske aber theoretisch können
einzelhändler unter berufung auf das
hausrecht auch künftig eine masken
pflicht für kunden und mitarbeiter
bestimmen die faz hat nachgefragt und
erfahren große lebensmittelhändler wie
lidl aldi oder edeka werden davon wohl
keinen gebrauch machen sie verweisen
darauf keine ersatz gesetzgeber zu sein
außerdem findet die möglichkeit zur
kontrolle
unterdessen möchte die bundesregierung
die quarantänezeit von kogit infizierten
auf fünf tage verkürzt das sieht ein
vorschlag des gesundheitsministeriums
und des robert koch instituts vor das
angebot kostenloser bürger tests bleibt
bis ende juni bestehen und das hat die
faz erfahren kommende woche könnte im
bundestag über eine sofortige
impfpflicht ab 50 jahren abgestimmt
werden nach der sommerpause könne anhand
der infektions lage dann entschieden
werden ob auch eine impfpflicht ab 18
jahren aktiviert werden soll
wie geht europa künftig mit china um
auch um diese frage geht es heute das
verhältnis zwischen der eu und peking
ist angespannt wie nie auf einem
virtuellen gipfeltreffen
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen und
ratspräsident michelle nun chinas
staatspräsidenten ski die liste der
punkte in denen sich die eu und china
nicht einig sind ist lang nun kommt der
krieg in der ukraine dazu und der damit
verbundene und erst gestern abermals
bekräftigte schulterschluss zwischen
china und russland
die spitzen der eu wollen jean ping der
noch dazu drängen seinen einfluss auf
vladimir putin zu nutzen den krieg zu
beenden
in einer repräsentativen umfrage durch
das münchner ifo institut unter 4000
deutschen unternehmen die der faz
vorliegt plant jeder zweite hersteller
die importe aus china zu verringern
wichtigster grund die abhängigkeit von
dem land reduzieren durch corona lockt
uns immer wieder stillstehender fabriken
und häfen in china brächten den gesamten
warenkreislauf in der welt in gefahr
insgesamt 40 prozent geben zudem eine
generelle politische unsicherheit als
grund für ihre nachlassende begeisterung
für das china-geschäft an
und auch das bringt dieser tag in doha
werden heute abend ab 18 uhr unserer
zeit die acht gruppen für die fußball
weltmeisterschaft in katar ausgelost
zwischen losglück und todesgruppe ist
alles möglich katar ist als gastgeber
gesetzt ansonsten ist die fifa
weltrangliste für die zusammensetzung
der lostöpfe maßgeblich deutschland
gehört als zwölfter zu top 2 weswegen
sich die deutsche elf auf mindestens
einen sehr schweren gegner einstellen
muss im schlimmsten fall droht eine
gruppe mit brasilien polen und kamerun
oder alternativ mit frankreich senegal
und ecuador mit etwas losglück wäre aber
auch eine vorrunde mit katar serbien und
ghana möglich heute abend werden das
wissen wm eröffnungsspiel ist dann am 21
november
das war das wichtigste an diesem freitag
wenn sie zeit haben besuchen sie nachher
auch unser online-angebot auf faz.net
zum beispiel ein interview mit estlands
regierungschefin die sagt wir müssen im
ernstfall das feuer erwidern können die
wirtschaft berichtet über sechs pharma
frauen die die pandemie in schach halten
die finanzen fragen wie sichere ich mein
depot in krisenzeiten und das wissens
ressort erklärt was sich hinter aphasie
verbirgt nach dem plötzlichen
karriereende von bruce willis redet die
ganze welt ja über dieses krankheitsbild
in vielen dank fürs zuhören bei dieser
kleinen podcast premiere am montag hören
wir uns wieder wenn sie mögen und von da
an immer montags bis freitags sechs uhr
morgens der faz früh denker mit dem
wichtigsten des tages zum anhören gleich
nach dem aufstehen in allen ein schönes
wochenende
[Musik]